what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we have ourselves a
trailer for what is technically
Insidious 5 today called Insidious The
Red Door leave a like on this video so
the only reason I'm aware this trailer
came out is because I'm on upload number
six of the Mandalorian and uh can't seem
to get it to not get blocked I think all
my reactor friends are holding out on me
tell me what you guys did that
apparently I'm not doing
because I want to eventually go to bed
hopefully by the time this is up the
other one's up all right John thanks for
being here he's the bigger Insidious fan
that I so you better kill this
conversation best of luck to you Johnny
[Music]
are you ready
we're ready to forget the further once
and for all
okay forget
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
nice
foreign
did you ever try and get help no I'm
just trying to push through
is that guy Ty Simpkins
a few weeks before your students show up
right or the other one just an idea to
reconnect I know it's been tough with
you too
light and dark is what we're
you're in the art school I take it yeah
you go here too yes
an experience that defines you
know oh great
do you have any red
but I don't even remember being sick
deep into your memory
and let's see what life can find stop
going to the school this class
[Applause]
yeah we got a song backing crazy stuff
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past
so much you don't know when I was too
scared to tell you the truth our family
has been keeping secrets
they suppressed our memories but I can
still feel something following us
there's only one way to find out
let's go this looks like a fun house
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
something's getting closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
shoot what
oh he's back the red face is dead or the
lipstick face demon depending on Whose
terminal Darth Maul well that looks like
a fun movie sure does did Patrick Wilson
directing this one he is that's good and
Lee 1l at least came up with the story
ideas so he's continuing on from the
original nugget of sourdough that
birthed this bread I only have not seen
the fourth one John what is it the last
the last key last key I have not seen
that one how much elise's move but I
like it in this order one three two this
is cool that they got the original cast
back that's probably the most exciting
part because we technically get our
actual Trilogy now of the original
family yeah absolutely so I think that's
really neat and you know this looks like
more of a a fun house movie this has a
little bit more of a kind of feels like
not exactly Rob Zombie director
it's a little bit more of when I say
like fun house it is you know like a
like killer clowns at a theme park
sure it feels a little more it doesn't
feel quite as polished and as like fluid
as what James Juan does he doesn't seem
like he's trying to ape like all the
crazy hot head camera angles and things
it has more of like a Gothic but meets
like yeah kind of diy-ish sort of look
what's most noticeable to me is the DP
is definitely not the same because the
lighting does not have as much of that
visual striking quality to it but where
I feel like this movie might succeed the
most that will probably surprise people
is the fact because Patrick Wilson
directed it that we might get some great
performances and maybe even stronger
than the other ones because this is an
actor directing other actors and that's
usually the best thing they can bring
I'm hoping that uh yeah because right
now the scares and stuff look kind of
like they're just rehashing from the
other ones but it looks fun yeah I mean
I feel like with these movies the the
kind of difficult thing becomes you do
expect a certain kind of tone and you do
expect you know certain like multi-step
jump scares you know and and every time
you kind of gotta come up with a new
version of that and so yeah I I don't
know if they will be as slick and as
fluid as I don't know there's something
about James Bond where he seems like
he's just got an endless well of those
things but I also kind of look forward
to maybe Insidious being able to as you
pointed out kind of I don't know spread
out into maybe something a little bit
different because two each movie has
played on a slightly different
supernatural horror element even just
the first two movies you're jumping to
something more like Poltergeist with the
first movie to something kind of like
The Shining with the second movie so I
don't know I I hope that maybe they'll
bring inspiration in from some kind of
other like this does feel like a later
period horror movie than even what those
first couple are hearkening to in their
tribute Factor so uh I don't know like I
I hope this will bring its own kind of
Gothic flavor parts of it too I mean
certainly kind of reminded me of a
mishmash of both Insidious and The
Conjuring which I guess to many people
would probably not be a great amount of
difference but this seems kind of like
the the tone of a Conjuring movie but
with the colors of it it's hideous movie
to me if that makes sense because you
know Insidious I I associate with being
very expressive and expressionistic and
you know having yeah like these crazy
further ghosts and stuff like that where
you know this looks like it'll have its
like themed spirits and that but like
maybe it'll have a more like
psychological angle to it also yeah I
feel like there's something more to this
movie than perhaps they're not clueing
us and on right now I think they just
want to remind us that like the original
cast is back and flares of the first
couple are here in terms of the horror
qualities but I could see some thematic
things that they are bringing to the
table
um especially with you know because the
in the first movie it dealt with the sun
being lost in the further and then
realizing that the key was in the
father's past and now you know I feel
like some of those like sins of the
father passed down because this is like
a family suppression thing and then to
really break the the the lineage of all
this terrible deeds and the families I
haven't slept guys uh or whatever you
know I'm trying to say the family in one
way or another and we don't know what
what degree they all played into it but
yeah there's been efforts to basically
wipe those memories away instead of
dealing with them and giving Dalton the
whole truth and two you've got like a
great Boyhood you get to watch these
people I mean Patrick Wilson and Rose
Byrne don't look that much older but the
kids sure do oh man
ray Patrick Wilson still look great what
is he gonna take his shirt off and who
knows maybe we'll get a spooky ghost
Lynn Shay in the future or something I
hope so I gotta get this like a jigsaw
thing where they find like endless ways
to keep on bringing her back I'm
surprised that as Sony pictures produces
I thought this was like a universal
rewarder Brothers movie yeah a universal
blumhouse I don't know maybe maybe
they're finally ready to but yeah I'm
excited for Patrick Wilson and um hey
guys what did you think about the
Insidious trailer did you happen to get
your Mandalorian reaction unblocked on
YouTube
tell me how you did your secret
maybe we could use it too later on why I
want right now as we're talking there's
one that's 37 checking so I just gotta
wait like seven more minutes this this
upload pans out uh Hey assistant
oh my God John it works I think it
worked it worked shout out someone oh my
goodness Gabriel you're an angel you're
the first name that I saw and we're
going with you
it's okay Gabriel understands because
Gabriel is full of grace he is an
understanding and beautiful gentleman
and hey if there's anybody who could
save us from the Demonic uh uh you know
hellscape the the further realm uh being
haunted by copyright claims and blocks
and whatnot it's you buddy you clearly
you did it you're the secret weapon
you're the charm and we love you for it
so stay pledged and we'll catch you next
time be well cheers
foreign